>> AS THE PRESIDENT -- PEOPLE
ARE DYING.
>> DO THINK THERE WAS BLOOD ON
THE PRESIDENT’S CONSIDERING THE
SLOW RESPONSE, OR IS THAT TOO
HARSH OF A CRITICISM?
>> I THINK THAT’S A LITTLE TOO
HARSH.
HE SHOULD STOP THINKING OUT LOUD
AND START THINKING DEEPLY.
>> Shannon: ANOTHER DAY,
ANOTHER ROUND OF CRITICISM FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE MEDIA --
IS THE MEDIA DOING AN OBJECTIVE
JOB BACKING RELEVANT QUESTIONS?
PARTISAN LEADERS GIVING IT
ADMINISTRATION A FAIR SHAKE?
LET’S DISCUSS WITH FOX NEWS
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, SHANNON.
>> Shannon: OKAY, SO A PIECE
IN THE AMERICAN THINKER UNDER
THE HEADLINE OF THE UNBEARABLE
PETTINESS OF THE WASHINGTON
PRESS CORPS IS THIS.
"EVERY PRESS DEMO QUESTION IS
MEANT TO IMPUGN THE PRESIDENT’S
HANDLING OF THIS GLOBAL EVENT.
IT’S ONE OF THEM WANTS TO CATCH
HIM IN A MISTAKE SO THE CLIP OF
THEIR QUESTIONS WILL GO VIRAL."
WHAT DO YOU MAKE THE COVERAGE?
>> WELL I DO THINK THAT SOME OF
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS IN
PARTICULAR CONSPICUOUSLY NOT TO
INCLUDE OUR OWN JOHN ROBERTS WHY
THINK IS PLAYED THIS VERY
STRAIGHT AND VERY ABLY, BUT TOO
MANY OF THEM ARE STILL TRYING
TO, YOU KNOW, PLAY THE OLD GAME
THAT YOU DO OF, YOU KNOW, ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS INTENDED TO SHOW
THAT SOMETHING THAT TRUMPS IT
PREVIOUSLY WAS INCONSISTENT WITH
SOMETHING -- THAT’S FINE FOR
NORMAL TIMES.
THESE ARE NOT NORMAL TIMES.
THOSE BRIEFINGS THAT ARE BEING
HELD AT THE WHITE HOUSE ARE
REALLY A FOUNTAIN OF
INFORMATION, SOME OF IT PROVIDED
BY TRUCK HIMSELF, ALTHOUGH HE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME BRAGGING AND
SAYING WHAT A GREAT JOB THEY’RE
DOING AND GETTING INTO TUSSLES
WITH REPORTERS WHO ASK HIM
ANNOYING QUESTIONS, BUT EVEN
FROM HIM THERE’S REAL
INFORMATION.
BIKE PANTS DOES A GOOD JOB OF
SUMMARIZING WHAT’S BEING DONE IN
THE GOVERNMENT AND TO HELP THE
STATES AND THEN DOCTORS FAUCI
AND BIRX HAVE BEEN EXCELLENT IN
INTERPRETING THE DATA COMING IN
DAY BY DAY AND GIVING US A SENSE
OF HOW THIS PANDEMIC IS
SPREADING, YOU KNOW, WHAT’S THE
GOOD NEWS, WHAT’S THE BAD NEWS
AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY
FOR THAT.
I’M A POLITICAL JOURNALIST,
RIGHT?
YOU THINK I WOULD BE THE ONE
WHO’S MOST ABSORBED WITH THE
POLITICS OF ALL OF THIS BUT WHAT
I’M INTERESTED IN JUST AS A
CITIZEN WATCHING HIS BRIEFINGS
DAY AFTER DAY IS MORE TO THE
TELL US ABOUT THE VIRUS, WHAT
THEY TELL US ABOUT THE PANDEMIC,
WHAT ARE THEY TELL US ABOUT OUR
NEW YORK IS DOING AND WHAT ITS
DEATH RATES AND ITS
HOSPITALIZATION RATES -- WHAT IS
ALL THAT STUFF TELLING US?
I THINK A LOT OF REPORTERS
AREN’T ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT STUFF AND THEY’RE MISSING
SOMETHING.
>> Shannon: AND LISTEN, THE
PRESIDENT LIKES TO SPAR WITH
THEM.
HE IS GAME AND READY TO DO IT,
BUT HE’S ALSO TAKING ON THIS
IDEA THAT GOVERNOR CUOMO IN SOME
CORNERS IS GAINING RAPIDLY AS
SOMEONE WHO COULD SOMEHOW
MAGICALLY BE THE DEMOCRATS
NOMINEE.
IF THE PRESIDENT NOT AFRAID TO
TROLL A LITTLE BIT WITH THAT.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> NOW, IF HE IS GOING TO RUN,
THAT’S FINE, I WOULDN’T MIND
RUNNING AGAINST ENTER.
I’VE KNOWN ENTER FOR A LONG
TIME.
I WOULDN’T MIND THAT BUT I’LL BE
HONEST, I THINK HE’D BE A BETTER
CANDIDATE THAN SLEEPY JOE.
>> Shannon:
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON THE
HEADLINE WITH THE CUOMO 2020
FANTASIES HAS ABOUT 2020 REALITY
IS THIS.
FLIRTATION, SUCH AS THAT IS,
SEEMS MOST INSTRUCTIVE FOR WHAT
IT SAYS ABOUT THOSE DRAWN TO IT.
REVIVING A PERSISTENT TROPE
AMONG TRUMP ERA DEMOCRATS, THE
ROMANTICIZING OF PROSPECTIVE
PARTY SAVIORS, EVEN AT THIS
POINT IN THE NOMINATING CALENDAR
AND THERE WERE NEW POLLS OUT
THAT DEMOCRATS STILL HAVE
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT BIDEN,
15% OF BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTERS
SAY IF BIDEN TURNS OUT TO BE THE
GUY, THEY WILL GO OVER AND VOTE
FOR TRUMP.
IT SOUNDS LIKE DEMOCRATS ARE
STILL LOOKING FOR THAT ONE
PERSON THEY THINK CAN BE THE
BEST MATCH AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> AND ANOTHER REASON FOR THAT,
SHANNON, IS THAT SINCE HIS QUITE
SHARP DEBATE PERFORMANCE IN HIS
LAST ROUND WITH BERNIE SANDERS,
BIDEN HAS BEEN STRUGGLING, YOU
KNOW, HE’S BEEN OFF THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS, AND
HE’S BEEN DOING THESE PIECES OUT
OF A HOME STUDIO IN HIS HOUSE
AND HE SAID SOME SERIOUSLY
AWKWARD MOMENTS DOING THAT AND
HE DOESN’T HAVE A JOB.
HE DOESN’T HAVE A ROLE.
HE CAN’T GET UP AND DO WHAT
CUOMO, FOR EXAMPLE, IS DOING,
WHICH IS TOO BRIEF ABOUT THE
EFFORTS THAT ARE BEING MADE AND
TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE AND
CUOMO, WHO CAN BE QUITE ELEGANT
AT TIMES, PHILOSOPHIZING ABOUT
THIS WHOLE MATTER AND SO ON AND
HE’S BEEN KIND OF AT THE TOP OF
HIS GAME.
AND IT’S NOT HARD TO UNDERSTAND
WHY DEMOCRATS WORRIED ABOUT
BIDEN, WORRIED ABOUT HIS AGE,
WORRY ABOUT HIS EVIDENT SENILITY
AT TIMES.
WOULDN’T LOOK AT YOUNG
ANDREW CUOMO AND SAY I WISH YOU
WERE OUR HORSE.
THE MECHANICS OF IT THOUGH, AS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
SUGGESTS, ARE PRETTY HARD TO
IMAGINE.
WERE GOING TO HAVE A CONVENTION,
THEY’RE GOING TO BE DELEGATES
WHETHER IT’S A VIRTUAL
CONVENTION OR AN ACTUAL
CONVENTION.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN, BUT THE
CANDIDATES WHO HAVE AMASSED THE
DELEGATES IN THE PRIMARY PROCESS
ARE GOING TO BE THE ONES WITH
PEOPLE VOTING FOR THEM IN THAT
CONVENTION.
AND IF YOU DON’T HAVE ANY
DELEGATES, YOU DON’T HAVE A LOT
OF LEVERAGE.
WHAT WOULD HAVE TO HAPPEN WOULD
BE FOR BIDEN TO WITHDRAW FOR
SOME REASON AND BIDEN’S
DELEGATES AND PERHAPS SOME OF
SANDERS’ AS WELL, WOULD HAVE TO
SWING THEIR COMPORT TO THE LAST
MINUTE CANDIDACY OF
ANDREW CUOMO.
IT’S NOT IMPOSSIBLE, BUT IT’S
HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
>> Shannon: A LOT OF
INTERESTING NUMBERS IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" "ABC NEWS"
POLL.
AND THEY COME ON THE DAY THAT
BERNIE REASSURES HIS FOLLOWERS
HE IS NOT DROPPING OUT.